Our last lesson covered
the basics of Turing machines.
At the beginning of last lecture,
I said that the Turing machine precisely
captures an ocean of computation.
In this lecture we will give strong
evidence for this Church-Turing thesis,
the statement that everything computable
is computable by a Turing machine.
The Church-Turing thesis is named for
Alan Turing and Alonzo Church.
Church had an alternative model of
computation known as the Lambda
calculus, which turns out to be exactly
as powerful as a Turing machine.
We call the Church-Turing Thesis,
a thesis because it isn't a statement
we could prove or disprove.
In this lecture,
we'll give a strong argument
that our simple Turing machine can do
anything today's computers can do.
Or anything a computer could
ever do in the future.
>> To convince you of the Church-Turing
Thesis, I'll start from the basic Turing
machine and then branch out, showing
that it is equivalent to machines as
powerful as the most advanced machines
today, or in any conceivable future.
We'll begin by looking at
multi-tape Turing machines,
which in many cases are much
easier to work with.
And we'll show that anything
a multi-tape Turing machine can do
a regular Turing machine can do, too.
Then we'll consider
the random access model.
A model capturing all the important
capabilities of a modern computer.
And we will show that it is equivalent
to a multi-tape Turing machine, and
therefore must also be equivalent
to a regular Turing machine.
This means a simple Turing machine can
compute anything your Intel i7 can or
whatever chip you may happen
to have in your computer.
Hopefully, by the end of the lesson
you'll have understood all these
connections and you'll be convinced that
the Church-Turing Thesis really is true.
Formally, we can state it like this,
a language or a function for
that matter is computable, and
I've used quotes here to indicate
that we mean this in the common meaning
of the word, not in the technical sense.
If and only if it can be decided,
or in the case of a function,
computed, by a Turing machine.